birds in the pokemon world do remain
relatively similar sharing key features
like beaks and talons features which we
know appeal to mark's masochistic side
so with that as our base i felt pretty
darn confident that this time we'd be
able to hit a home run
i present to you markiplier's new
perfect pokemon
it's beautiful mark if you are not into
this one then i i know you must be
trolling me at this point look at it the
power the mystique why is it hiding its
eye behind those beautiful feathers what
psychic power does this thing truly hold
joking aside i think more than anything
this taught me and hopefully
just like algorithms can't form the
perfect show so too can algorithms not
design the most smashable pokemon so you
know what i went in and threw away my
checklist i scrapped the numbers and i
trusted my gut knowing everything that i
know about mark i made what i guarantee
to be his perfect irresistible pokemon
just try to pass on this one
hold on
wow
[Music]
smash
well done
vast improvement